each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we're going to have a fantastic keynote
by winme whoo-hoo is Walter Sanders AMD
chair of Electrical and Computer
Engineering at the University of
Illinois he has a PhD from the
University of Berkeley California
Berkeley and he has received many many
many awards for his work in architecture
and software for HP sees he received the
1983 attack upon ooh outstanding young
electrical internet world the 1994
surak's award on for faculty research
and many other words he's going to be
talking about high-level programming in
a mini course and please help me to
welcome him thank you thanks thanks for
thanks for that extremely warm
introduction but I hope I can live up to
22 the person you introduce okay so this
is really a lunch talk so I promise no
compiler of flow analysis no dependence
analysis no equations and then you know
anything else you want me to take out I
will so what I like to do is to give you
a little bit of a a journey of you know
how we're dealing with you know engaging
people who are actually doing menu
programming today and what are the kind
of things that we believe will have to
be technologically advanced in order to
really help these people and so the work
involves a lot of people and this is the
picture of the UPC RC Illinois team and
you know there are 17 faculty members
many of them are here so I see many many
faces here and so you know there are a
few aspects that you will probably get
even better you know what treatment
about subject you know by talking to
them this afternoon so you know
instead of taking a nap after lunch you
know you should go to the sessions or
talk to some of my colleagues so the
vision is you know for you pcrc Illinois
is to make parallel programming easy and
we're good well especially want to focus
on simple programming patterns and you
know there will be some very very hard
problems and we believe that if we help
people to solve the simpler problems
first then we have a chance of attacking
the harder problems right now I
personally believe that you know a lot
of these problems have to do with the
tools not being able to engage the real
development process and workflow and
people's real needs so the topic says
many course so you know what I'm just
kind of going to quickly go over you
know what I mean what I mean is the kind
of processors that will have limited
resources very limited resources you
know what mostly the resources will be
dedicated to the compute units so when
you have lots and lots of them and then
you will have you know relatively small
amount of control so in some ways it
could be a CPU that is kind of you know
in terms of reduced core complexity or
reduced c'mon caches or GPU today you
know what you will see you know typical
examples of these many core types that I
will be talking about here so you know
the first thing we learn about many core
is you know it only makes sense to
program this menu menu course if you
care about performance or scalability or
both so if you don't care about either
of those you know you really should save
your time and if you just write you know
very simple piece of coaching sorry well
run better on the cpu okay so you know
don't don't bother with that and the
other lesson we learned is that
performance on a single chip versus
scalability across different chip levels
actually share a lot of the same
techniques that people need to use so in
many ways the fur
order effect of getting performance on
these chips is to make sure that your
program scalable and the techniques that
what I'm going to be talking about that
many of these developers wish we can
help them with fall into that category
and then there are some detailed
performance tuning some you know fairly
fine tuning kind of things that you can
do but those are in general second order
effects so you know many people were
even tell you from some of these vendors
that you may or may not even be worth
while trying to do some of those kind of
fine tuning even for a particular
generation okay so what I would like to
to you know to convey to you is today
there is a major gap between the
programmers need and what the tools are
actually are doing okay and it's our job
people in this room to be able to fill
that gap and being able to empower these
people okay so there are three important
things that you know almost every you
know many cool programmer would tell you
that okay you know if they're successful
in doing what they do they will tell you
there are three things that in general
they probably did right the first one is
you need to have massive parallelism in
your application you know what if you
don't have parallels in uh it's not
going to be good so in general people
are finding most of that in the data
parallelism today okay and the second
one is regular computation of data
accesses you will need to be able to
somehow either have some kind of regular
application or regular data set that
falls on your lap which means you're
lucky or if your application algorithm
or your data is not quite regular then
you need to work hard to regularize it
and regularization is actually something
that is you know that that is going to
be the key in this whole game you buy
regularizing things you also create some
of the work and avoid load imbalance ok
and I'm going to show that I may not
even show you
some data because it's a lunch break but
you can the loading balance what they
that Nandi should uniform data
distribution can really make a huge
difference in terms of performance of
these devices and then they will finally
say well you know a lot of my time is
spent on two smaller things one is
dhiren bandwidth okay and you know you
may appear like a small thing but that's
probably where people spend most of the
time today trying to optimize the data
access patterns and use the on-chip
memory to cut down the amount of
bandwidth demand that the applications
are putting on the chips and then the
drm system then the second one is a
little more subtle conflicting updates
to you know what memory locations and
you know a lot of the straightforward
parallelization involves atomic
operations critical sections and these
things in general destroy the
scalability of these algorithms so a lot
of the work is actually in turning their
algorithms inside out you know changing
some of the you know that replicating
some of the states so that you can avoid
that kind of situation and then get
scalability and often time performance
okay so you know what you will say well
you know it's a really the case in
general you know it may be a few years
from now people will be building
hardware that you know the regular data
accesses will not be important maybe
Intel will figure out a way to build
some kind of magical hardware that you
know the memory bandwidth would no
longer be a problem and you know I sure
hope so you know what I computer
architect as well so you know what I
would like to be part of the team to
build that magical device okay I really
would love to so if Intel comes to me
and say here's a piece of technology and
fabrication technology can you come head
up this team and you will build that
magical device I will quit my university
job and join Intel today okay put it
this way so but you know if history
makes any sense it tells us that
whenever you want to manage a massive
amount of parallelism you do need to
have some kind of regular usage pattern
otherwise it's not going to work whether
its military on top you know Army Navy
you know Air Force or manufacturing
agriculture you know what this is closed
this is close to my house you know the
second one and you know banquet you know
what have you ever been in this large
banquet word the chef says please let me
know exactly how you want to customize
your food you're lucky that the chicken
gets to you why is still warm right so
you know that's what read latency and
regularity means right in large-scale
systems and this is a picture probably
taken not too far away from this
location you know on the left hand side
you know what for those of you who had
to you know come to from the airport
around maybe five o'clock you know what
you know what that Nick picture it means
so but you know what whenever the cars
can maintain some kind of regular
pattern everyone can progress whenever
you start to have some a a name people
going like zigzag like this and then
people start to hit their brakes you see
what happens to the traffic pattern
right you start to see stars so that's
why you know what you know I am
relatively you know a pessimistic about
the possibility of eliminating some of
these regularization techniques that
people need to use in programming these
many droid ships in the future so there
are a few things that you need to you
know you need to overcome in order to
get to success civilization due to
conflicting act updates you know
oversubscription or critical resources
and loading balance you know what bad
things happen when you have it was
things were you know the regularization
process start to break down and you know
where you start to have irregular in the
world you know congestion so what are
the things that people need to do I
ended up doing something pretty stupid
in the past three three months I agree
to edit the first two volumes of GPU
computing jams so we ended up with
almost 300 submissions and we carefully
read through even with all the proposals
and then picked about a hundred and ten
ones that we believe are reasonably
successful that people have you know
been successful in doing their
applications and they presented a case
of how they reach success some kind of
recipe you know some kind of you know
what a repeatable you know a description
of what they did out of the hundred and
ten when I read through all the work I
started to realize that they invariably
go through pretty much the similar
process the in general need to
understand the relationship between the
domain problems and computational model
that's one thing the first thing that
that jumps out you know there are many
many different models for doing the same
kind of you know goals right you know
science in the engineering in the video
processing domain and you need to
understand that level the second one is
you need to understand the strengths of
limitation of your computing devices
very few authors who have some kind of
you know Iranian description about the
strengths and weakness of the chip will
ever be able to get performance out of
them today and the third one is
implementing those models to steer away
from the weakness so essentially they're
practicing techniques needed to
translate from undesirable patterns to
desirable patterns it's all that's all
about but one of my former students that
you know said this to me is that after
he he finished his thesis I said you
know what did you learn John and John
said boy we never solve any problems we
never ever solve any problems we push
the problems around to places where they
matter less right so it's all about
pushing some of these things into the
unity under the carpet or you know
around the corner where no traffic is
there and you know
they don't matter that much and then you
start to get real performance out of
these things so let me kind of a you
know comment on you know a little bit
philosophy here you know this is a slide
that you know Dave frontega david
patterson and he cited you know a fairly
widely known you know seven dwarves and
there's you know initially there are
seven types of computation and you know
structure grids and structure griz fast
Fourier transform even though Dan said
yesterday that you know FFT is not an
application but it's a very important
component of every application dan sorry
it is to me is still very important and
I'm still learning something about FFT
every day so the point of using this is
to say you know what we is we have a
reasonable way framework for this
particular you know a taxonomy to
understand the general types of
applications or in what the general
types of you know data structure
computation that people do but what this
one doesn't teach us is exactly how
people are getting performance out of
all these hard times applications from
my experience there is a small set of
techniques that people can use to get
good performance out of all these types
of applications so this is what I call
the seven techniques in many call
programming and what the first one is
scattered together transformation the
second one is granularity course ending
register tiling third one is data access
styling for locality first ones data
layout and traverse ordering get better
in world access patterns and dumb
bending and cut off being sorting and
partitioning for non-uniform data when
your data start to behave badly and the
fit finally is hierarchical queues and
you know accuse a Colonel's for dealing
with dynamically changing and
dynamically generated data okay so after
reading through all the hundred and ten
chapters I started to you know say okay
well I can map pretty much what everyone
did and all those works into a subset of
these seven techniques they're good so
at least we have something here so what
I'd like to do is to you know to give
you a little bit of sense of what how
these techniques are actually being used
by real programmers and but the point is
I would like to you know get you started
thinking and hopefully i will also give
you some good indication of how the
future tools how the future languages
will fit into this kind of workflow ok
so the first one is scattered together
transformation whenever you have a
quadratic kind of computation where you
have lots of the input you have lots of
output and each output is going to be
affected by some significant number of
input that's how you get large amount of
computation time a lot of these
calculations is often time very
convenient to express your your
computation in terms of inputs that is
given each input what are the outputs
that should be affected there's a good
reason for this in most of the
engineering and science computation the
output tend to be more regular than the
input okay weather is many your embody
problem where you're calculating some
kind of force grid whether it's a
medical imaging problem where you're
trying to take some skin data and
generate some kind of regularized
volumetric data the output tend to be a
lot more organized and or regular than
the input data so that's why it's very
natural to say to write a piece of code
say okay go get the next input which
will give me the input is going to give
me some kind of coordinate and some kind
of value and then I'm going to do
something and you can calculate the
extent to which the input were affected
data but in many court execution this is
a disaster waiting to happen because
that input oriented programming is going
to
create these threads that will be trying
to write into a range of output and they
start to trample each other so you need
to have some kind of atomic operation
but these things tend to create long
latency some weight and so on because
they just need to line up so in general
the first thing that a lot of these
people do is to convert the execution
into output oriented expression
essentially say every thread is going to
look at one output and it's going to
figure out what are the inputs that is
going to need in order to produce the
output easily said than done because
remember I said the input tend to be
less regular than output so given an
output is in general not very easy to
find the input I'm going to come back to
this point but in general that's the
first order transformation that these
people tend to do and the second one is
threatening and registered howling we
all know that parallel computing in
general would require some kind of
redundancy if you truly want to have
clay to do something and you want to
trap Mike to do something you know in
general you don't want them to have to
communicate with each other so if there
are some lot of things that each one can
do locally you don't want them to
communicate you want them to just go
ahead and do them you know but
personally so I'm showing a you know a
fine grain paralyzation where each chunk
is a threat and then there you know what
let's say two redundant piece of work
followed by you know one unique work and
then some redundant work and you will
have you know let's say 12 of these
threats that you can schedule into some
kind of mini coach Chip and then just
you know execute them often time it
becomes desirable to fold several work
with threats worth of work into one
bigger heavier threat so that you can
calculate the redundant work put them
into the register a register somewhere
in that and then have the other
equivalent threats folded into the
threat to enjoy that piece of work this
essentially sacrificed on parallelism
but we all know that
register access can be extremely
efficient so at some point if you have
too much parallelism then oftentimes the
real weight of getting efficiency and
then even scalability in some ways is to
create large enough threads that can
actually do / conserve memory accesses
and you know what calculation based on
the register storage Jim demo students
did a register the matrix multiplication
method which you know makes use of you
know essentially this concept and you
know what Jim that I'm not going to you
know to give you opportunity to you know
to hit me with a you know a hard
question about that but that's my
perception of involves one one good
thing that you did you know you actually
created a lot much bigger usage of the
registers so that you can conserve the
bandwidth requirement you know more on
that chip so the third one is beta
access tiling and this particular method
you know what essentially has to do with
the following once you you you converted
your AG your computation from out input
oriented into output oriented then you
have all this gather pattern and but the
gather pattern is going to require too
much memory bandwidth to get all that
data in so what you what what you want
to do is you want to actually start you
you know what create some execution
phases where only a small chunk of the
the input data will be actively used by
a large number of sweats so you will
stage these in word that the data chunks
into the on shape memory and then
whenever you have a chunk into the
ancient memory they will be consumed by
all the threats that are waiting for
that and for desert the algebra this is
of extremely effective method if you can
do this don't use anything else as far
as memory bandwidth is concerned but you
get more difficult when you start to
have ghost sales for PDE solvers when
you have ghost cells for convolution
algorithms for media processing kind of
things then you start to you know that's
where a lot of the developers start to
trip because they
takes actually some intellectual power
to be able to figure out the real
benefit of Kylie once you get to that
level and that's where some of the tools
will definitely begin to help data
layout transformation so in many data
structures we are we declare the data
structure as a multi-dimensional array
and each element each element of the
array is actually a strut so we can just
formulate that as another dimension of
the array so in this picture where I'm
showing a you know three dimensional
array and XY actually only two of the
dimensions and then I show all the
elements that are in each array element
each element in the in the array so we
can do a rail structure you know a
layout which is the original layout and
this tend to be a very very good cpu
layout and I think one of the the talks
that seek a lot gave in what alluded to
this particular issue and then you can
convert that into structure of a rape
and in general whenever you don't have a
effective way of tiling your algorithms
such as LBN just by converting from
struct of a regular right to array of
struct a real struck into struct off
array you can actually create enough of
the memory coalescing and then in fact
so that you can conserve a large amount
of memory bandwidth other the current
GPUs and that will give you about four
times a performance on a gtx 280 today
what you really want to do is actually
what we call the tired array of Coyote
array struct offer a tired array of
structs or tile actually tired as a
struct of array and essentially rather
than moving all the elements all the way
out so that you essentially gather all
the elements together from each
dimension you actually create these
little chunks of the
the elements and then you essentially
repeat this pattern and what you really
do is you take part of the lower
dimension of the original array and move
them into the low dimension so this
gives you a good compromise between
three things one is coalescing needs and
the other one is actually memory channel
utilization in the GPUs this gives you a
way to actually spread your active
accesses across the six to eight memory
channels in the chip today and the third
one is if you ever need to use the same
layout for CPUs this gives you better
locality because you are not spreading
the nearby element in the world struck
elements in too far you know what such
as the same elements from the same
original array into faraway places
they're going to be much closer to each
other for CPU caching so this tend to be
the kind of compromise an expert
programmer will do for something like
lbm and to a lesser degree many other
you know gridded applications the first
one is input bidding I'd mentioned very
briefly that input data tend to be a lot
less regularized than output regular
than output so the way people deal with
this problem is by piece of pre sorting
these input data into some kind of pins
or some kind of categories they can be
you know as irregular as some kind of
spatial trees like KD trees quadtrees
octrees you know all these different
kind of tree structures or in some
applications when the data is
sufficiently uniform distributed you can
use you know regular regular sized
spatial bins and whenever you can get
away with the regular spatial bins you
don't want to go to the more exotic you
know data structures because you have
much easier access into these structures
and this is a molecular dynamic
application where you know what the
force calculation has a certain you know
cut off distance so for each grid point
you will have a certain number of bins
that need to be
considered so if you sort these inputs
into these bins then you converted a
irregular batch of data into a much more
regular array structure that you can
easily index and identify and create you
know a parallel access so that's you
know what routinely done and then if you
look at a typical you know electrostatic
force calculation you know you will see
some kind of interesting tricks to avoid
some of the beans like giving something
exotic in a formula in terms of the list
that you knew calculate the consequence
of not doing this can be severe if you
don't do the bending you know what and
you start to you know you're forced to
look at every everything before you can
determine whether you need to process
the input for large data set you can
actually have you know that a GPU can
actually run much much slower than a
sufficient CPU implementation but if you
pay attention to bidding then you regain
all the data scalability okay now 61
being sorting and partitioning this has
to do with non-uniform data distribution
not all the data in the real world are
uniformly distributed I wish they are in
fact if they're all uniformly
distributed my job as a tool developer
would be a whole lot easier but when MRI
people come you know there was first
give me some you know semi uniform data
and then you know once we give them some
good performance they would say oh by
the way I have a spiral scan data that I
need need to be handled and you look at
this ah then this huge data in a
non-uniform distribution so in general
the most effective way that people deal
with this those kind of data today is by
taking the input data sort them into
some kind of order Dean's and then also
limit the bin size so that some of the
some of the the input will fall into the
GPU bin okay a CPU bin and by limiting
the data then you have you can actually
do a prefix can to identify the
boundaries of the implicit bits they
don't need to be the same size but
that's why prefix can is so
is such an important calculation in
theta parallel computing and then so you
once you define the bin boundaries then
you can you know load the section of the
bins that are that are important to each
thread into the on-chip memory and you
as you can see that the rage could be
dynamic so you may have a situation
where you may not have enough space to
hold all the base necessary for these
two threads so that's where you actually
will need to default into the main
memory so in general if you have look at
some of these applications they will
actually first test if the input falls
in the range of the on-chip memory if
not they go to the go to the drm and
then fetch the ones I cannot be wouldn't
build into the on-chip memory and this
is where you cross from a naturally
organized data okay regular data into I
artificially regularize data okay and
this is where a lot of the tricks are
this is where a lot of the mistakes are
being made and this is where a lot of
the tools should help none of the tools
that I know of help with any of this
okay so that's the reason why as a to
develop right look at this and look at
how what people are doing and I lower my
head and say shame on me okay I'm not
tuned into that process 71 when things
are dynamic like graph algorithms like
you know what things that are
dynamically identified and say this is
my next batch of dynamic data that I
need to bark process in general the way
to get performance out of that kind of
application today is the correct
hierarchical queues where you use
threats to produce you know what cute
cute data elements at the court level
which takes advantage of the fact that
the hardware is going to be mostly in
what you're going to mostly have these
processing elements that are active at
the same time so if you provide the
different cues to dip
and processing elements then the
contention would be minimized if not
totally eliminated so you can provide
let's say for the current sm for a
nvidia GPU you can provide a qs for the
eight processing elements as they do
these contact switching and so on
different threats will be accumulating
into the same queue but they would be
doing this in turn however you need to
be careful because more and more GPUs
will be executing more than one warp at
the same time so you still need to use
atomic operation otherwise when you move
into Fermi you can actually cause
problems you can actually cut bugs in
your code now after each thread block is
done then you know what you can
accumulate you can actually write all
your output into the into the block
level Q and after the the colonel is
done then you can you know take the
block level Q and then write it into the
global q once you get beyond that the
warp level and get beyond the block
level the contention will be minimized
so it's all about scalability of your
dynamic assembled data you know how do
you avoid having a bottleneck inserting
the next batch of data into that that
you know structural structure so
correspondingly people also have been
doing hierarchical in a colonel lunch
for these kind of applications in
general let's say if you are doing a
breadth-first search algorithm you will
start with a source and then you kind of
grow your frontier and you can go into a
large number of nodes but then at some
point you may also shrink at some point
depending on your yield constraint but
in general you will grow more than
shrimp so at the beginning if you are
processing only a small number of
frontier nodes and you have to launch
your kernel and do global Optima a
synchronization you lose all your
performance so they're usually three
levels of colonel in these
high-performance libraries one is the
small kernel that only has one thread
block and that uses barrier
synchronization that's intrinsic
in the hardware and do the
synchronization and just do that do the
frontier propagation until the frontier
grows big enough then they would go to
the second you know what sex second-tier
kernel that I think Jim students i
actually have been using essentially you
launch only the enough thread blocks
which will at most equal to the number
of SMS in your hardware and then the
language allows you to do a global
synchronization across the thread blocks
so that will take care of about 10,000
up to about 10,000 thread you know what
notes in the algorithm and eventually
you have enough of a big frontier that
you just launched your Colonel every
time and then you terminate the kernel
for the global synchronization but when
you have so much data to process that
launch overhead is no longer the biggest
issue so you will see this kind of you
know pattern in a lot of the dynamic you
know graph oriented applications so the
reason why I talk about those three
techniques here is really this these
tools need to fit into the workflow this
is where these those are the things that
most of the men equal programmers spend
their time they're spending all that
time trying to you know you get those
kind of techniques done and so the tool
should help them to form a fishing
kernels out of these things provide
clear performance model you know what
there should be a very clear way for
them to say oh this is a good car no
this is not a good colonel for my data
you know it should be a very easy thing
to do right right and then you know what
you need to support software engineering
when people apply these techniques
portability you're somewhat crafts there
colonel you know with these techniques
are these kernels portable not portable
two different you know targets
architectures testing how do people test
these kernels in what was once they're
done and how many times they new
capacities things and you interface
integrity assumption verification a lot
of times when people apply these
techniques they actually need to make
some assumptions about how the rest of
the code is behaving the pointers you
know the some of the data structures
shapes
and so on and currently there's no way
for the system to help them to enforce
these assumptions for check these
assumptions at runtime and say oh you
know what just what you're assuming here
is not really what's happening in the
rest of the code the legacy code is
doing something weird here you're not
going to be able to do that parallelism
that you want okay but it's not there
right so that's why we believe that you
know what these tools and applications
really need to be code designed so that
the tools are feeding into the kind of
the places where people are really doing
most of their work okay so this leads to
what we're proposing for the second
phase of you pcrc Illinois so we have
three big chunks ever scholar safe speed
and acrobatics so that ever scholar is
the component word they're developing
some very demanding applications some of
them are already in the many course and
some of them are in both you know many
core and multicores today but you know
there will be continued performance
requirements out of these applications
and through the process we are feeding
these developers with the safety tools
and performance tuning tools and
essentially what repeating we're asking
the same question again and again why
don't people use the tool you know why
are they spending three days here
without any tool help you know what's
going on here right and so that we can
begin to really tune into their
development process and this is a slide
that marks near generate here that
generated here then which I really like
you know it's a it's a kind of a little
bit philosophical but I think it is a
very important point the point is
currently we have a compiler you know
what model where we generate different
implementations of the same code and
then we have the user mode you know user
model where the user will generate
different code versions you know through
that whole process of you know
performance tuning there's nothing in
between and whenever the user cannot fit
exactly into this mode you know they
just get out of completely out of this
mode and then use you know you use hand
to do all these things i really think
that the
one of the biggest challenges is to
actually provide something that can
actually engage the user in a somewhere
in the middle so that the users would
not do these things by hand totally but
then the compiler would not be will have
to do all that you know all the heavy
lifting totally by yourself it's easier
said than done for all of us will have
any kind of experience with that process
it is a very very big challenge so you
know what I have a few of these you know
what in applications that you know what
for example here for gesture interface
component students already have a
implementation the GPUs like this near
real time but they still have real
stability issues so they can take
another ten times our performance just
to get to the real stability of you know
a sensor free gesture detection right so
you know what their you know surface
reconstruction work by john hart
students same thing you know what you
can reconstruct you if you really want
to you know what do you know a good
quality you know reconstruction of these
surfaces and so on for interactive you
know what virtual presence you know we
have still have a long way to go in
terms of the you know what we can do in
motion detection then read mention some
of this yesterday in what detecting
emotion is not based mostly on that met
the volumetric image rather than the
real you know a gridded surface
reconstruction so we can i still have a
way long way to go in order to get more
reliable you know detection of the
emotions so you know what we organize
these projects into you know what
refactoring has which will tap into the
you know the higher level programming
pass that that implements part or whole
of the seven techniques in the
transformation and we currently only
have partial implementation of the three
three of the seven so you know it's not
a easy task but we're definitely making
progress and one of the things I you
know we're very excited about the
project is that you know what some offer
you know what we both we all understand
that we're trying to be aggressive in
terms of speed power and so on but I
think there's a aspect of safety net
that has been you know really overlooked
a lot of the future does past tools that
is whenever people make these you know a
big brain surgery on some up part of the
code for performance they really are
making some significant interfacing
assumptions so you know when some of
these assumptions are being violated at
runtime there's no one that are checking
these things it's not just for you know
necessarily for paralyzation even for
code update even for you know just
regular software update they routinely
these kind of problems that prevent you
know what it costs a lot of costs later
on for the software support and we're
developing a piece of technology that is
checking and isolating these you know
assumptions at runtime and minimize the
debugging and supporting cause of these
kind of things so you know what a safe
safe speed project you know what I
didn't spend a whole lot of time on it
but they really you know provide a good
level of scrutiny over the code base for
it you know parallelism so there's
something evil plan you know actions for
the sponsors and you know what as usual
and so but one of the things that we
believe what need to happen in the
future is not just you know Intel and
Microsoft we really need to you know
begin to you engage some more of the is
vs so this brings me to the final slide
here you know what you know this is you
know very well known you know what
phenomenon of value of death you have a
whole bunch of research you know what
that that are you know what is very nice
and then you have you know some you know
a startup company doing some kind of
tools and so on but then you have you
know very few things that you can
actually take from research and
successfully apply to these things you
know whenever you try to get some you
know high-value kind of research into
the commercial world there is a valley
of death so you know what we're saying
here is yes the value of that will be
there
yes some of our tools will be dead you
know on the other hand the only way that
these tools will be able to some of them
will make their way into the commercial
world is by giving the developers what
they want and I think we have a much
better understanding for this particular
domain what people want I didn't talk
about the entire domain and I don't want
to spend the rest of the afternoon
introducing these other domains but I
hope that that gave you a good sense of
our philosophy or you know what research
you know techniques and you know how we
actually how we feel that these tools
that we're developing will be different
from the tools that people have been
developing in the past 30 years there's
a different level of engagement that
we're doing with the developers so with
that thank you very much for your
attention and you know what I would be
happy to answer a couple questions yes
so with all these transformations Stefan
right but with all these transformations
who discuss their speed to the extreme
elegance of it
the focus on how yes the other one is to
go to a level of expression abstraction
where the developers expressing less
about the data layout for the algorithms
yes we're in your experience with which
of these two passes the more successful
or what's your okay intuitively you
would expect the second one to be more
successful in the first one to be less
successful in practice the first one is
more successful in the second one is
less successful the reason is because of
the sorry state of you know of what
we're providing people don't trust us so
they'd rather you know do all the things
themselves and at least they know what
they're testing and they're you know
what so so that's that's that's a reason
but to me you are actually pointing to a
very important point unless we start to
to tip that balance the productivity is
always going to be popular so you know
that that's actually the key of the
problem when can we tip the balancing
point for them to start to trust some of
these tools that they would start to use
the testing methodology that we provide
as part of the tool rather than doing
the explicit test themselves and that's
going to be the real any other questions
yes hey
so a couple of things that we we did
learn one is we can complain about these
you know these this Hardware all day
long you know what every time every time
I have a teacher course and every time I
see some developers the first thing they
say is oh you know why do I need to do
co lacing you know it's such a pain
right now I need to do corner to attune
turning and all that stuff and so one
thing that I think hardware people need
to really decide is you know what you
need you you really need to communicate
your faculty to people you know what
what are the things that that you you
would not be able to do in the future
okay a lot of these people are still
hoping that you know you will be able to
reverse that trend maybe you will if you
will come out and say clearly that you
will but if you can't you know come out
and say you know this is something that
the tools and the programmers will
really have to take care of it because
that in this decision in that
communication process is very harmful
okay the second one is you know what I
actually learned that CPUs for any
successful many core processor the part
that the CPU does is incredibly
important so if you look at all the
regularization processes most of the
techniques can only be done on the CPUs
today so there is a there is a very
important part that I think you know
what there you could put cpu and GPU
into a competition mode and say okay you
know whatever bulk processing you would
do I would do but I think there's a
low-hanging fruit where you know a lot
of these regularization processes are
not necessary supported by the CPU is in
the most efficient way though you know
what that may be one of the things that
you know the Intel architects should
take a look at any other questions
if not you oh yes Jim yes so where's
auto-tuning fitting into this framework
so auto-tuning to me is a parameter is
kind of an implementation you know a
parameter setting kind of thing so in
general if you look at all these seven
techniques they're there lots and lots
of parameters that each technique will
end up you know in the code so that's
you know that's why i didn't miss
auto-tuning as part of the seven to me
it is a you know it's a final
implementation phase where you set
finalized the parameters for those yes
yeah huh oh you mean the algorithm book
yes I as soon as I go back I'll start
writing what it is in fact so one is
referring to the you know the GPU
computing gems books Volume one is
coming in coming out in December and we
already finalized all the contents on
the scene production it does take about
four months to come out so there will be
50 articles in 10 application areas and
the second one will come out in June and
that's going to be the next seven
application areas plus the frameworks
and tools so there will be a total of a
hundred and ten articles and you know
that's where i extracted some of these
you know observations as well okay thank
you